all flavor no grease is a new version of
bringing unity to the community through
food nobody has died on the street no
gunfire within the last night five years
[Music]
there's a ceasefire and a peace treaty
going on from the consensus a hole on
108 Street my name is Keith Garrett and
I am the owner of all flavor no grease
[Laughter]
[Music]
all flavor no grease actually started
out of my mother's kitchen the way my
mother made a taco was lettuce tomatoes
cheese sour cream ketchup hot sauce so
that's the way I started and then we
transitioned into our food truck which
we are in now the kind of food that I
serve I would have to put it under
Americanized Mexican food and only
reason why I say that is because I do
serve tacos burritos quesadillas and
enchiladas but I don't make them a
traditional way by now it's a whole
different feeling flavor baby
[Music]
[Music]
when you really think about it we're
bringing together all flavors of people
from gang members to politicians and
there's no confrontation no blood being
spilled there's no grease being spilled
anywhere but yeah we still got all
flavors here I would love to go to the
the property areas and to just to let
them know that you can make it there is
a such thing as hope but you have to
work gotta get your ass up and do
something to see 500 plus people pull up
to my truck it really makes me think
about one person and his name is for
real I'm so happy
[Laughter]
[Music]